how old are you seven but i look a lot
older
what happens when movie makeup and
prosthetics aren't enough
de-aging can give actors facelifts make
their hair fuller and shinier
and even change their height from
filming flashbacks to creating immortal
characters here are the most realistic
age-defying cgi transformations
created for film what is it they've sent
us
hope to bring carrie fisher back for a
cameo at the end of rogue one
the vfx team had to recreate a young
fisher without just
reusing old footage their solution was
to use a different actress who was
actually older than fisher had been
while filming a new hope
but who had a similar face and body
shape norwegian actress invil dilla
played princess leia her costume
included a perfect recreation of leia's
outfit
to make sure fischer looked exactly like
she did in the first star wars movie
motion capture dots were placed on the
stand-in's face and fisher's face was
then superimposed over hers to bring a
young leia back to life
and de-aged the actress in a creative
way by combining a new actress's body
with old footage of an icon
for leia's single line they had the
stand-in recited but then
inserted carrie fisher's actual audio
from a new hope
into the final version of the film lola
vfx was the special effects team behind
it
chapter 2 and the only challenge more
terrifying than creating the perfect
pennywise
was trying to make the loser club look
young again it's
really about changing like reversing the
physionomy
a team of 20 artists had to study each
actor and their character from the first
movie
comparing things like height weight and
skin blemishes
the least amount of changes were made to
sofia lillis who changed the least
between movies but jeremy ray taylor who
plays ben
had to have baby fat digitally applied
to his face and stomach
while finn wolfhard who plays richie had
to be made to look shorter
thanks to a massive growth spurt his
face is also brightened and smoothed
making the cgi on his character
definitely stand out the most compared
to the others
did you miss me richie cause i've missed
you
no one can play captain jack sparrow
like johnny depp
who almost caught captain jack
so instead of hiring a look-alike actor
to play a younger version of the
notorious pirate in the fifth film
the vfx team had depp perform all the
flashback scenes himself while a body
double took careful note of all the
actors movements and mannerisms
the body double then performed the same
scenes so that they could use his skin
as a model for how younger skin would
move and behave
they then laid a digital copy of his
skin over depp's face
creating a cgi combination of the two
actors that's pretty realistic
i don't see how that's a party while
revisiting the cinematic battle of new
york in 2012's the avengers the cast of
end game was digitally de-aged because
marvel didn't want to just re-use old
footage
scarlett johansson in particular had her
face subtly de-aged and even her hair
was partially cgi
to better match what it looked like in
2012's film just check out the
difference between how she looked in the
avengers and the remake of the battle
compared to how her character evolved
for end game
making samuel l jackson look 30 years
younger for the entirety of captain
marvel is one of the most ambitious
de-aging projects yet
oh you want to get personal for the
first time
lola vfx's team was able to create a
much younger character
without using a body double the artists
took
inspiration from how jackson looked in
some of his 90s era movies
thanks to some dots on his face the vfx
team was able to map out his features to
make nick fury's face thinner
brighter and smoother creating an
incredibly real cgi effect that fits
right in with marvel's other digital
achievements
nicole kidman already looks eternally
young but for aquaman's opening
flashback scene the vfx team had to try
and
represent the passage of time by making
a younger version of queen atlanta even
more radiant
it was easy cgi was used to digitally
retouch her face
lines and wrinkles were smoothed out
completely and her skin was brightened
to add a youthful
glow hiring orlando bloom to reprise his
role as legolas in the desolation of
smog was an
epic idea but it came with some serious
vfx responsibilities
ah i wish i was 10 years younger not
only does the hobbit series take place
years before the lord of the rings but
legolas is also supposed to be immortal
to make bloom look like an eternally
youthful elf they digitally smoothed and
lightened his face
and even brightens the color of his eyes
the effect makes his skin look
too good at moments but since over a
quarter of the movie is cgi his slightly
uncanny appearance fits
right in is marvel the industry leader
in de-aging effects
it sure seems like it when robert downey
jr showed up as a young tony stark in
captain america civil war
audiences couldn't believe how realistic
he looked
downey performed the scene himself and
then they digitally lifted his skin
changed the way the light hit his face
to create a youthful glow
and removed discoloration and dark spots
while using his old films as reference
the vfx team compared the process to
meticulous photoshopping they went
through almost
4 000 frames and edited each one to
perfection i know you did the best you
could
to de-age michael douglas for the first
ant-man movie they used a body devil
but for ant-man and the wasp they were
able to re-sculpt the actor's face
by modeling it after some of his older
films they used the tried and true dot
method and then restructured the actor's
face
and darkened his hair in post-production
to create a young hank pym
i like this i like this marvel world
making a young janet was done the same
way using michelle pfeiffer's 80s movies
as references
particularly the witches of eastwick
michelle
pfeiffer 30 years younger hope you'll
also notice she has
impossibly youthful and voluminous hair
cgi was used a bit here too to add
extra shine and fullness x-men the last
stand was one of the first movies that
showed us
just how impressive cgi de-aging could
be
we're mutants gene we are like you
to make patrick stewart look about 20
years younger his wrinkles were ironed
out on computers
and his age spots removed all the extra
smoothing
and lifting of his face did leave him
looking like he had
a bit of an egghead but it was the first
major use of this tech in a blockbuster
film
which in general used some of the
coolest visual effects
of the time a lot of makeup was used to
make kurt russell look young again for
guardians of the galaxy vol 2
which is partially why the effects are
so realistic but cgi was still 100
necessary to smooth out wrinkles
and tighten and lighten the actor's skin
that's first of all what's very
enticing aaron schwartz provided the
facial reference for the character
acting out all of russell's scenes in
the same way he did to get the movements
just right then they grafted parts of
his face onto ego
creating a perfect 80s version of the
character
gemini man was one of the first times a
d aged character had a main feature role
in a film
the vfx team actually created an entire
digital version of a young will smith
and laid it over will's performance
this helped them get the expressions and
actions just right while also creating a
character whose face and body
are subtly different from the actors
this movie revolutionized the aging tech
allowing the creation of a completely
freestanding digital model that could
realistically star in films i got lucky
another film that helped get the ball
rolling on aging technology
is the curious case of benjamin button
this movie did some
incredible things to brad pitt director
david fincher
used cgi in nearly every scene which
involved applying a phosphorescent
powder to pit's face
and using dozens of greyscale and
coloured digital cameras to create a 3d
image that could capture
every small detail and expression they
were great
they could even change the character's
body by grafting his face onto other
actors
to star in american pastoral jennifer
connolly was de-aged by approximately 25
years to look just like she did in the
1991 film
the rocketeer while you've probably
noticed that de-aging tech
often slims down actors faces this time
the final result was
achieved a little differently they
actually added more fat to connolly's
face particularly to her cheeks
chin and jawline this made her seem more
youthful compared to her already slim
facial features
i'm mary dawn dwyer and i love your son
while kurt russell's de-aging process
involved makeup it might surprise you
that lola vfx
usually requires actors to wear almost
no makeup when shooting these scenes
to properly map faces they like to see
how light reflects off a bare skin
as well as the look of natural pores let
us know in the comments which cgi
transformation
impressed you the most